SHORE GETS A CHECK ON IT.
VERMETTE TOOK IT AWAY, HIS
PASS GOES BEHIND THE NET AND
THE COYOTES CAN'T GET CONTROL
OF ITS AS BROWN GOES OVER.
MAC COLIC WITH
BAT ALE LONG THE BOARDS WITH
10:40 TO GO IN THE FIRST
PERIOD.
HANZAL OUT TO THE COYOTES.
THE FIRST GAME OF THE SEASON
FOR THE COYOTES.
AND THE KINGS HAVE A THREE ON
ONE, COME AGO CROSS TH THE SHOTT
DIDN'T CLEAR THE ZONE.
MARTINEZ TRIED TO HOLD IT
BACK, MURPHY AGAIN, STEPS
AROUND A DIVING THING AND NOW
COMES OFF THE STICK THERE OF
CHIPCHURA.
AND THE KINGS HAVE IT.
BACK
PEARSON.
>> I EXPECT TO HIT DUDEY OVER
THE HEAD.
EVERYTHING BEHIND THE LINE,
THOUGHT IT WAS CHANGING THE
PATH OF THE PUCK.
>> MOVERS TO THE MIDDLE, ZONE E
ICE.
>> COYOTES BRING IT RIGHT
BACK INTO THE ZONE.
BACK TOGETHER, JORDAN WEAL.
>> WEAL'S PASS INTERCEPTED,
SHOT AND
BACK OUT TO CENTER ICE.
MUZZIN CHASES IT DOWN, HE GAVE
IT TO GREENE.
GREEB GREEN TO THE BLUE LINE,
BROWN STOPPED BY HANZAL, AND
SCORE FROM THE LEFT SIDE,
TOBIAS RIEDER, ICE, AND CLIFFORD
TAKES OUT TWO COYOTES WITH ONE
CHECK.
AND THE LINES MAN WENT DOWN,
TOO.
THAT'S A HAT TRICK.
PICKED UP THERE BY AS THEY TRY
TO MOVE IT OUT FRONT.
AT T DOMI
ACROSS THE LINE, DIVING IN
DEEP ON GREENE.
HITS THE SIDE OF THE NET AND
HE GETS HIT.
PUCK COMES OUT TO THE BLUE
LINE.
HERE IS CART EAR CROSS THE
LINE IN FRONT, SHOOTS,S NEED THD
KEEP THE PRESSURE ON THE
COYOTES.
CLEARED FROM THE COYOTES LINE
AND MARTINEZ BACK TO GET IT.
>> PICKED ALL SKILL LEVEL
ARE WELCOME.
JOIN HIM ON SUNDAY.
>> YEAH, I'LL BE RUNNING.
>> JORDAN WEAL GETS THE BASE
OFF, TO CLIFFORD, SHOOTS AND ANY
LIEU ZIP.
AND A BLOCK AND A SAVE.
KOPITAR IN THE ZONE, KOPITAR
IN DEEP, WRAP AROUND ON HIS
PASS, COMES BACK TO THE BLUE
DROPS IT OFF AND CLEARED OUT
TO CENTER ICE BY THE COYOTES
AND PICKED UP BY THE KINGS
CARTER.
MOVES IT AHEAD ON A SHOT,
ANOTHER SAVE BY SMITH, SHOT BY
BROWN, UP THE MIDDLE, MUZZIN,